hey everyone stares register nurse re  and calm and in this video I want to  show you how to properly remove soiled  gloves so our goal is to remove our  gloves without getting the stuff that's  on our glove on our skin or on our scrub  so what we're going to do is we're going  to take our thumb and our index finger  and we're going to pinch the cup of one  of the gloves then we're going to take  the glove and kill it all and we're  going to grasp the glove completely in  our hand and close our hand tight  prevent it from hanging down because we  don't want to touch it then we're going  to take our index finger of our  unclogged hand and we're going to slide  it underneath the cup of the glove and  we're just going to peel it off and it  fits it in a nice little Bunch and then  we're going to throw it away and wash  our hands thank you so much for watching  and don't forget to subscribe to our  channel for more videos